one of the stars of the Vegas Golden
Knights their left winger James Neal
joining us on the program James
congratulations thanks for joining us
thanks a lot
you got a couple off days what do you do
on your off days yeah we just had two
off day so I just regroup a little bit
get some fast we got a little more than
expected but it's always good this time
here wait do you do anything fun I mean
we we all hang out a little bit we had a
barbecue the other day with bunch of the
guys and just laid low but nothing too
crazy you know where we're at that time
of year where rest is a success how
surprised are you that here you are in
the second round playing the Sharks no I
think you know how confident we are with
our game and how well we played all year
I thought we you know we were ready to
play the Kings or fast team and we knew
exactly what to expect I mean I think we
I don't think any of us thought we would
beat him in four but you know we felt
felt good about our game and the way it
went so it's nice yeah but this doesn't
happen to an expansion team James if I
would have told you at the beginning of
the year I know you're going to at least
the second round of the playoffs in all
honesty what would you say no I know but
that being said two expansion teams
don't usually get marc-andre four years
or goaltender's dream you know you know
management and everyone puts put
together put the pieces in place to put
together a really solid team so you know
when we went into camp when we started
you know getting to know each other and
becoming a hockey club you know I think
we new year we're gonna be competitive I
mean I think we did a little bit better
than everyone's thought but we had good
players so when you have that you know
you're all building toward some and you
want to win and you want one for each
other and good things that good things
happen so it's been a lot of fun my fans
have been insane and and it's just been
an amazing ride so far well you know I
liken this what I saw with Nashville
last year and then you certainly see
that in vague
with these fans but describe that
fanbase or what it's like for a home
home ice game to people who haven't
experienced that
yeah rink is Wawrinka its unique spot
for a rink right on the strip there
right so people can party all day have
fun and do whatever they want on the
strip and and then they walk right down
the street a little bit and you walk in
the t-mobile into our arena so the
atmosphere our rink is it's intimate
it's it's it's tight it's a tight rink
so fans around on Tapia so you can hear
them you can see lemon when you have
that it's you know makes it fun every
single night so they love it
you know there's two million people that
live live in Vegas that you wouldn't
expect all you think of is a strip so
there's a lot of local people that are
here and are dying for a hockey team so
they've really made it their own and
we've really enjoyed playing in front of
them
you got celebrity fans I think you got
everything we got you know on it
as we continue to go here I'm sure will
be more and more so obvious fans but
yeah is there someone heard a game ever
played it it's pretty cool to see you
get the nickname big game James that's a
lot to live up to what do you think of
that nickname I just got that nickname a
few days ago I'll take the game jeans
too so thanks but yeah you just try to
you know you these are the games you
play for this is the time of year you
want to be at your best then you have a
big game you want to call you out then
I'll take it but I like the real deal
since its Vegas and its cards so the
real deal
Neal I get that yeah I get that
do you know what you have in common with
Alex Ovechkin Jonathan tabes and Patrick
Kane I do okay wait a minute
James is gonna do a stat of the day he
doesn't know he's doing a static
yes Thomas Thomas man okay all right
okay so he's aware of his stat of the
day let me give them music here and then
you're gonna give your own stat of the
day here James so seat and hit the music
[Music]
no no no now you can we have our own
house band okay so I mentioned these
players and I wanted to know if James
Neil knew what he had in common with
alex ovechkin Jonathan James Patrick
Kane and Thomas Vanek so go ahead with
your own stat of the day James yeah my
own Saturday no I start I start 20-plus
goals and all 10 seasons I've played so
that's just out of the day
well I let my teammates know that
Saturday here comes that what stat of
the
James congratulations feel-good story
and a great story for the NHL and
certainly for that that city as well
Congrats and thanks for joining us
that's James Neal Vegas Golden Knights
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]